[Music]
when I write these film analyses I
usually start by watching the film with
a notepad and writing down all the
things I think are interesting when I
started watching Wong Kar Weis in the
mood for love the first thing I wrote
was 5 minutes in and every shot is a
frame within a frame meaning that every
single shot feature characters not only
framed by the rectangle of the film
itself but by smaller internal shapes as
well and this is a visual technique that
filmmakers have used for decades
my favorite example is the great last
shot in John Ford's masterpiece The
Searchers but seldom is it used
so ubiquitously as the film went on I
had to cross out five from my little
note and change it to six seven nine
it wasn't until minute 12 that I saw the
first shot without some foreground
obstruction this shot which crucially
doesn't feature either of the two main
characters but wait I'm getting ahead of
myself in the mood for love is the story
of two married couples who happen to
rent rooms in the adjacent homes of
older couples in 1960s Hong Kong the
film focuses on the husband of one
couple mr. Chau and the wife of the
other mrs. Chan as they both gradually
discover that their spouses are cheating
on them with each other and then how
those two innocent victims of infidelity
come together to deal with the pain of
that the film manages to be
unsentimental with its subject matter
while couching the events in sumptuous
painterly cinematography the narrative
skips and jumps forward through time at
an erratic speed as one might recall the
story in memory and the viewer is often
left initially confused as to how much
time has passed between scenes this
prompts a strong engagement with the
film a need to pay attention but it also
reflects how the film was made there was
little more than an outline when Wong
kar-wai and his crew began filming a
process that took a long 15 months in
which the script and the individual
scenes were written on the fly by the
director and the actors together which
is surprising because watching the film
you can
help but feel that you're in the hands
of somebody in complete control visually
and emotionally in the mood for love is
fully consistent the film is so
self-contained that it only features a
handful of locations each filmed from
the same angle so that you experience a
kind of circular effect of returning
again and again to the same things
this technique far from feeling sluggish
or repetitive instead isolates against
fixed backgrounds the things that
actually are changing in the film the
inner lives of the two leads and for the
most part these inner lives are explored
wordlessly the real action of this movie
is in postures glances and touches and
by restricting the language wong kar-wai
echoes the restriction of action that
plagues mr. Chau and mrs. Chan in 1960s
Hong Kong where they are under constant
threat of gossip a kind of surveillance
from their landlords and the community
at large eating that sounds in game this
is one reason why everything is doubly
framed by placing objects in the
foreground the director enhances the
feeling that the characters have of
being observed not to mention our own
feelings of being observers observed and
observing scene and being seen what we
desire from others what others desire
from us these are major themes of in the
mood for love I think the most
extraordinary element of this film is
what's introduced just after the two
main characters admit to each other that
their spouses are cheating instead of
confronting the situation head-on their
primary goal becomes to understand
exactly how it happened so we get this
incredible scene where they reenact the
seduction of their spouses in which each
attempt to embody the spouse of the
other while being coached by the other
on what they think the spouse really
would or wouldn't do Hong Kong good this
makes for a really complex but also kind
of perverse interplay though the film
aggressively focuses on only mr. Chau
and mrs. chant to the point of never
showing the faces of their spouses we're
always aware that for people not to are
involved here but it's not for real
people it's two people and two phantoms
I think of what's being asked of Chou
and Chan in the seduction scene and the
guise of understanding what happened
each victim attempts to seduce their own
spouse in the form of the others spouse
a task that has to be doomed from the
start because the fact of the affair
itself means that neither Chao nor Chan
can any longer elicit that kind of
desire that they're trying to recreate
you could describe this course of action
as masochistic and Wong kar-wai lets us
feel this by not making it obvious when
mr. Chow or mrs. Chan are being
themselves or being each other spouses
often were a minute into the scene
interpreting it one way before the
reality or perhaps the unreality of the
moment hits us like a gut punch but
because each player is constantly
coaching the other they're able to
construct a fantasy in which they
control their own betrayal
I think moves he's gonna come with it
and by never consummating their own
budding love for each other mr. Chow and
mrs. Chan can infinitely delay the
moment in which they have to see things
as they really are they can stay in
their fantasy it's a tragic and twisted
state of affairs and Wong kar-wai has
said that if Tony Leung and Maggie
Cheung weren't such beautiful actors the
darkness at the center of their
characters and their fantasy would be
obvious of course they can't keep it up
forever and in the scene where mr. Chow
finally admits his love for mrs. Chan
most of the fantasy comes crumbling down
as he says they are like their spouses
which means that the thing they've been
refusing to see their own lack that
they've ceased to be an object of love
for their loved one rushes into
consciousness like a wave and yet still
they don't act on it it can only let the
brutal
truth in so much in order to survive in
order to move forward mr. Chow and mrs.
Chan doomed themselves to missed
connections this is why at the end the
film jumps forward to see them just
missing each other twice just missing
each other the mere possibility of a
connection not the connection itself is
what sustains them now everybody lives
within fantasy within frames
sometimes the frames are made by us
sometimes they're made by others
sometimes we need to believe that those
made by us are made by others but
whatever the case there's no way out of
the frame when fantasies rupture or
crack or break down completely
that's trauma like living temporarily in
a storm Wong kar-wai is in the mood for
love is a gorgeous quiet and painful
exploration of what happens when the
fantasy you create for yourself is a
perverse one when it only serves to keep
you from confronting the pain that it
was created to avoid and the reason the
film is so heartbreaking is because this
kind of perversity is really quite
common to all this
[Music]
hey everybody thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed it god I
love this movie if you think that the
nerd writer is something that you're not
seeing anywhere else on YouTube and you
want to help support it help me keep
putting the time and effort it takes to
make videos like this you can pledge to
my patreon page that would be awesome
you guys have been amazing and every
little thing helps you can click here
right now to do that as little as $1
thanks again and don't forget to
subscribe if you haven't already to get
all these videos and stay tuned for some
really cool stuff coming up some cool
collaborations coming up and here are
some more videos
[Music]